this video is brought to you by nordvpn
give yourself options online go to
nordvpn.com forward slash bio to get a
two-year plan at a huge discount plus a
free gift more on them in a bit
captain william bly was the man behind
the most famous mutant in history the
mutiny on the bounty but was he truly a
cruel tyrant a slave driver who pushed
his crew to the brink of desperation and
who commanded his ship with an iron fist
or was all of that just fiction
attributed to a man who has been
unjustly maligned by history let's find
out as we examine the life and the
career of william bly and take a look at
the real story behind the mutiny on the
bounty
william blyer was born on september 9
1754 in either plymouth devon county or
the village of santoodi and cornwall his
parents were francis blair a customs
officer and james pierce to say that
william bly was made for a life on the
sea would be a huge understatement he
sailed on his first ship at the ripe old
age of seven as captain servant aboard
the hms monmouth the position that he
technically held for eight years between
1762 and 1770. he didn't really because
he was just a kid but this was a move
done at the time to help boys gain more
sailing experience at least on paper so
that it would be easier for them to get
commissions later on since these
required a certain number of years at
sea of course this kind of privilege was
not afforded to any wafe who stumbled
onto the brig off the streets it was
only because francis bly was a customs
officer that he managed to secure this
position for his son therefore by the
time william bly obtained his first real
position aboard a ship he was already a
salty sea dog on paper in 1770 the 16
year old bly sailed aboard the hms
hunter as an able seaman which paid
better than the entry-level ordinary
seaman by 1771 blair was already able to
become a midshipman which was the lowest
ranking officer position later that same
year he transferred the hms crescent at
the same rank where he spent the next
three years of his career fortunately
for bly it did seem like he had some
genuine skills to complement that
non-existent experience of his besides
being a natural when it came to sailing
and navigation he was also good at
mathematics writing and illustration so
he proved himself useful aboard all the
ships that he traveled on from the
crescent he transferred to the ranger
and from there he joined the hms
resolution in 1776 where he was promoted
to sailing master this was not only an
impressive move for the 22 year old but
the resolution was commanded by none
other than captain james cook so bly
joined him on his third and final voyage
which ended with cook being killed by
native hawaiians before getting the
flesh boiled off of his bones not
exactly a fitting end for the captain
but most of the crew made it safely back
to britain and bly even earned some
praise for the skills and behavior he
displayed during the crisis his services
were in demand but he decided the maybe
some r r would be in order after that
ordeal and so he took a break for most
of 1780. during that time he met and
married elizabeth betham and the couple
would go on to have six children
together in february 1781 bly resumed
his nautical career aboard the hms belle
pool again as a sailing master this time
though he saw some action as he took
part in the battle of doga bank during
the fourth anglo-dutch war we have no
idea about how he acted in combat but
apparently his performance was
impressive enough to warrant another
promotion this time to lieutenant i
spent the next couple of years serving
as a lieutenant aboard several ships
including the hms cambridge where he
sailed alongside a young cabin boy named
fletcher christian that name will become
relevant in a short while anyway bly saw
more combat in 1782 fighting at the
siege of gibraltar under lord howe as
part of the american revolutionary war
at that point the war pretty much ended
in north america but spain and france
kept the conflict going eager to take
britain down a peg or two in the naval
power rankings it wasn't until 1783 the
hostilities ended and this put bly in a
bit of a conundrum he could have stayed
in the royal navy but now that britain
wasn't fighting anymore his chances of
upward mobility decreased significantly
since there were already plenty of
officers to go around bly's goal was to
become a captain of his own vessel so in
1783 he decided to leave the royal navy
for a spell and join the merchant
service this strategy paid off bly
started off as a commanding lieutenant
and in 1786 he achieved his ambition
being awarded the captaincy of the
merchant vessel britannia as a bonus he
reunited with fletcher christian who
joined the ship as an able seaman but
was soon promoted to second mate as
captain bly took a shine to the young
sailor together they sailed to and from
the west indies a couple of times but in
1787 william bly received an offer that
he could not refuse to sail for the
royal navy again this time as a captain
aboard the ship hms bounty
in 1787 william bly rejoined the british
royal navy with his old rank of
lieutenant but was immediately promoted
to lieutenant commander as part of his
new job it was a pretty sweet gig the
navy had this new ship called the bethya
which he had just purchased from a
private party and refitted at great cost
and then renamed it the hms bounty it
was a three-masted full-rigged
snub-nosed ship with no superstructures
and capable of only a 215 ton burden in
other words it wasn't particularly
impressive especially given that the
british royal navy had already got
around 600 other vessels at its disposal
there were other ships that were bigger
other ships that were faster so why was
the bounty chosen specifically well it
all came down to the mission that the
bounty had been chosen for this was a
scientific experiment more than anything
else my plan was to sail to tahiti fill
up the ship with loads and loads of
breadfruit the whole plant not just the
fruit and then travel to the west indies
hopefully with as much intact breadfruit
as possible so that it could be planted
there as a new and cheap source of food
for the slaves who worked on the
plantations the biggest obstacle was
getting the breadfruit to its
destination in one piece since tahiti
was in the middle of the pacific ocean
and the west indies were on the other
side of north america that was why the
royal navy asked botanist joseph banks
for help since he was the top dog of the
day in naturalist circles after serving
as the scientist aboard the hms
endeavour during captain james hook's
first voyage after looking over a list
of ship candidates banks was the one who
suggested the bounty and also
recommended specific changes that would
increase the chances that the breadfruit
would survive the lengthy journey this
included sheathing the bottom of the
hull and copper in order to protect it
from woodworms and transforming the
captain's quarters into a two-story
plant nursery lined with lead sheets
prevent water from spilling in it was
quite an ambitious project and the
custard brief it ended up costing more
than double the price of the actual ship
but where exactly did bly come in surely
given how much money the royal navy
invested in this little experiment they
could have found more experienced
captain or perhaps one with some
background in botany well actually we're
not sure why bly was chosen to captain
the ship usually the story goes that he
was recommended by joseph banks himself
perhaps the scientist was familiar with
bly's service since both had sailed with
captain cook albeit on different voyages
others pointed more to a straightforward
case of nepotism claiming that the
original private owner of the ship was a
man named duncan campbell who happened
to be the uncle of bly's wife elizabeth
regardless of how he got the job bly was
ready to go by the end of the year all
the extra stuff that was added to the
bounty meant that there wasn't room for
a lot of men or guns the ship only had
four cannons and 10 swivel guns and a
small crew of 46 like was not only the
captain but also the only commissioned
officer on board the ship accompanied by
43 royal navy personnel and two
gardeners one of those 43 was fletcher
christian whose presence was requested
by bly personally and he was promoted to
first mate on december 23 1787 the
bounty left england and sailed for
tahiti
the first leg of the journey across the
atlantic went rather well in fact the
only incident recorded in the log book
was a punishment of 24 lashes to a
crewman named matthew quintal for
insolence or contempt and even this was
done mainly at the insistence of the
sailor master john fryer who was second
in command aboard the ship and this
really brings us to the core issue
behind the mutiny on the bounty was
captain bligh really a tyrant who
deserved what he got by all available
accounts bly was more considerate and
less severe than the average british
officer of the time sure he swore and
shouted a lot and expected discipline
and competence but we have a detailed
logbook of all the movements aboard the
bounty during its year and a half
journey and there were only a dozen or
so floggings recorded and half of those
were for attempted desertion as one
historian put it he scolded when others
would have whipped and whipped when
others would have hanged other than that
two men named mills and brown were
punished by the negrog rash and stopped
for refusing to dance and no that's not
a joke apparently bly encouraged his men
to do various physical exercises such as
dancing in order to keep fit and he was
also quite fanatical when it came to the
cleanliness of the ship a habit he
picked up from captain cook but well i
was about it you could argue that both
of those idiosyncrasies
were for the good of his men the bounty
encountered its first major obstacle in
late march 1788 when it tried to round
cape horn at the southern tip of south
america to cross into the pacific ocean
there were some violent storms and
captain bly made the decision to turn
back and head for africa instead
rounding the cape of good hope and
entering the indian ocean he then
stopped in tasmania to resupply and
resumed his voyage towards tahiti
finally arriving at the end of october
during the first half of the journey the
bounty only lost one crewman named james
valentine who died of asthma whether or
not is when we're willing to admit it
bly's leadership kept them alive during
a long and treacherous expedition after
a 10-month long sea voyage the bounty
was in tahiti or oh to hate as it was
cool back then but the ultimate route
caused a lengthy delay which meant that
the precious breadfruit was out of
season by the time blair arrived he had
to wait five months until it was back in
season again the crewmen had no choice
but to spend five carefree leisurely
months in tahiti nothing but sun sea and
sandy beaches
all day long those poor bastards oh
really if we're being honest we're now
starting to arrive at the true cause of
the mutiny for your average illiterate
ill-mannered unwashed sailor titi was
paradise on earth sure they had still to
do some work but it was nothing compared
to their duties at sea plus many of the
men fletcher christian included fell in
love with tahitian women why would they
ever want to leave captain blair also
started to realize that his men were
getting a bit lacks and that he needed
to increase discipline almost all of the
lashings he issued happened during their
time in tahiti most of them for neglect
of duty or attempted desertion one
sailor named isaac martin was slashed 19
times for hitting a tahitian man showing
us that bly was also keen to maintain an
amicable relationship with the locals by
the end of march that breadfruit had
been grown collected and loaded onto the
ship the bounty was ready to leave
tahiti but what about its crew
now we'll get back to today's video in
just a moment but first a quick word
from today's video sponsor nordvpn
here's something you may already know
everyone uses the internet a little bit
differently and that's totally fine but
what you don't want to do is leave
yourself unprotected online you may have
heard me talk about what nordvpn could
do for you previously encrypt your
internet data move your online activity
to another location with just one click
either for superior security or new
streaming options all that is still true
nordvpn has more than 5000 servers in 60
countries but vpns give you access to so
many more options than just new tv shows
you having trouble connecting to social
media nordvpn want to buy a video game
that's cheaper somewhere else or maybe
not available in your country nordvpn
want to route your connection through
multiple servers just for double air
protection yes with nordvpn you could do
it all and that includes utilizing their
threat protection upgrade which blocks
ads eradicates web trackers and checks
for malware and so much more right now
as part of a special deal you guys can
get a two-year plan at a huge discount
plus an additional bonus gift on top of
that and if you try nord and change your
mind they offer a 30-day money-back
guarantee all you've got to do is head
to nordvpn.com forward slash bio again
that's nordvpn.com forward slash bio for
a two-year deal at a huge discount plus
a free bonus gift on top of that or just
follow the link in the description below
and now back to today's video
the bounty set sail out to tahiti on the
4th of april 1789 almost immediately
many of the men began pining for the
carefree life that they left behind the
build-up to the mutiny was a slow burn
however lasting for over three weeks
before the sailors decided to act
although this could also have got
something to do with them waiting for
the right opportunity on the night of
april 28th fletcher christian led the
watch accompanied by a few other
mutineers while everyone else was asleep
they arm themselves and enter bly's
cabin but well let the captain tell the
story for he wrote just before sunrise
mr christian and the master at arms came
into my cabin while i was fast asleep
and seizing me they tied my hands with a
cord and threatened instant death if i
made the least noise i however called
sufficiently loud to alarm the officers
who found themselves equally secured by
sentinels at their doors mr christian
had a cutlass and the others were armed
with muskets and bayonets i was now
carried on deck in my shirt in torture
with a severe bandage around my wrists
behind my back where i found no man to
rescue me the mutiny happened without a
drop of bloodshed once the other
loyalists saw the captain bly had been
taken captive they obeyed the orders of
the mutineers and here we have another
point against the whole bligh was a
cruel slave driver idea you might think
that the entire ship rose up as one and
cast off the shackles of tyranny but
that's not what happened of the 45 men
aboard the bounty 22 of them remained
loyal to bly that's right almost half
the crew sided with the captain four of
them were kept on board the ship by
force because they were too valuable to
release while the other 18 plus bly were
loaded onto a launch with a compass a
sextant a few cutlasses and about a
week's worth of supplies now don't get
the wrong impression blind as men were
placed inside a small vessel with no
chance no marine corometer little food
and water and cast off in the middle of
the ocean this was supposed to be a
death sentence just without anyone
really pulling the trigger but here was
where bly showed that he was genuinely a
brilliant sailor because he was able to
navigate across the pacific using the
few tools that he had at his disposal
and he had quite the challenge ahead of
him because the nearest friendly
european outpost was the island of timur
in modern day indonesia which was over 4
000 miles away first things first though
they absolutely need more supplies the
first place they reached was the island
of tefua which was not friendly but the
men would have never made it without
more food and water they did get into a
fight with the locals and quartermaster
john norton was killed but also they
managed to secure some more supplies
afterwards they tried avoiding unknown
islands as much as possible but still
had to make occasional stops on june
14th blair accomplished the seemingly
impossible and arrived at timor after
two months of rest he departed for
britain to inform the government of what
had happened despite his best efforts
five of his men were too ill from their
arduous voyage and they died before
reaching england but what about the
mutineers well they returned to tahiti
obviously but some of them had the sense
to realize that the british navy would
be coming after them for revenge and
that's just what happened in march 1791
the hms pandora arrived in tahiti and
captured 14 of the mutineers four of
them died in a shipwreck on the way to
england four were acquitted during their
trials for going along unwillingly two
were pardoned and four were hanged for
mutiny as for the other nine fletcher
christian included they quickly left
tahiti aboard the bounty with some of
the locals and established themselves
somewhere else it wasn't until almost
two decades later that we found out
where pitcairn island in the southern
pacific ocean by that point all of the
mutineers had died except for one man
named john adams who was eventually
pardoned the descendants of the men
still live on pitcairn island today
back in england bly was greeted with the
court-martial he did lose a ship after
all but he was not only exonerated but
he was promoted to the rank of captain
the evidence and testimony from
surviving crewmen at the bounty were
enough to convince the admiralty that
captain bly had acted within reason and
that the mutiny was not his fault
furthermore he even got the chance to
redo his last mission this time with two
ships instead of one after another two
years at sea his voyage to heat he was
successful and bly was honored by the
royal society that being said upon his
return to london the captain discovered
that his reception was decidedly
frostier that's because while he was
away the captured mutineers were brought
to stand trial and they all painted a
dark picture of the tyrannical captain
which swayed public opinion against him
and his reputation definitely took a hit
the image of the dreaded captain bly
that still exists today had begun to
form the remainder of his nautical
career wasn't exactly front page news
although he did take part in the
napoleonic wars and was praised by
admiral nelson himself for his role in
the battle of copenhagen in 1801.
curiously enough bly was also involved
in another mutiny during this time in
1797 his crew participated in the nor
and spithead mutinies although these
were more widespread throughout the
royal navy and were not the result of
anything blighted personally still it
was beginning to look like a pattern but
surely bly would not be involved in a
third mutiny i mean
surely not right anyway in 1805 bly was
appointed the fourth governor of new
south wales and australia back then
still a british penal colony on this
occasion it was actually the captain's
reputation as a strict disciplinarian
that won in the job new south wales had
fallen under the corrupting influence of
the thriving rum trade perpetrated by
the local military the new south wales
corps originally the regiment was
created to assist the governor but they
quickly realized that new south wales
was a long way from england and there
they had all the guns in power the rum
trade was so big in the region that
eventually rum became the de facto
currency in the colony since there was a
shortage of paper and coins therefore
whoever controlled the rum controlled
the local economy bly arrived in august
1806 with orders to end corruption in
the core and the rum trade monopoly
easier said than done considering that
the previous governors all failed and
the bly showed up without an army of his
own presumably the british government
thought the bligh could still make the
soldiers stand at attention and shape up
but just like his crew in tahiti these
men had gotten a taste of the easy life
and they weren't interested in giving it
up for king and country admittedly
tensions between the two sides rose
slowly for over a year bly tried to
steadily put new south wales on straight
and narrow but eventually he got tired
of this strategy and went with a more
direct approach and arrested one of the
main players in the rum trade the former
corpei master john mcarthur his trial
was supposed to take place in january
1808 but six core officers who were
supposed to preside over the proceedings
or refused to do so because well you
know they were his rum buddies bly then
wrote to them all to show up at
government house to face changes of
treason and you can probably guess how
things went from there again he did not
have his own army and most of the new
south wales corps were on the same page
so on january 26 1808 the regiment
marched to government house to pose
bligh placed him under arrest and took
control of the colony claiming that they
did it to end bly's tyranny the rum
rebellion as it came to be known still
represents to this day the only time
that a military coup took down a
government in australian history so who
knows maybe the mutinies were ly's fault
after all you know saying if you met a
jerk in the morning you simply met a
jerk but if you keep meeting them
throughout the day then chances are that
you're the jerk maybe bly had one of
those faces that you just wanted to
mutiny against blair was once again
court-martialed acquitted and promoted
pretty much the definition of failing up
but he never received another important
post in his career he died in london on
december 7th 1817 age 64 leaving behind
one question regarding his legacy which
still remains unanswered
captain bly villain
or victim